hi i'm richard campbell its excited to
be here it's the
to be at an NBC line
in London so because years I could tell
Docklands not actually London I wrote my
first line of code in 1977 of course
that's not the most important thing to
happen in 1977 the most foreign thing to
have him was Star Wars right yeah I keep
our priorities straight and that line of
code was written on a trs-80 model one
4k a ram cassette tape player for
storage 127 by 47 resolution graphics
and a version of basic not written by
Microsoft it was actually a tiny basic
and it only had three error messages
what how and sorry which I still think
is the best error message ever
now credit I am Canadian so I have a
special relationship with sorry but it
also is honest
I mean what's object not found but sorry
so divide one by zero sorry
I've done a few things since then and
maybe some of you are dotnet rocks
listeners anybody oh wow a few in the
room so my friend Carl Franklin started
the show back in 2002 I came on board in
2005 as of today there are 1511 episodes
please do not go through the entire
catalogue it's not worth it that a lot
of shows I have since 2007 made a show
called run as radio for IT pros once a
week since April of 2007 so I'm
persistent and we also for briefly made
the tablet show which in the context of
this story talking about the history of
dotnet it has a role to play so we
started it in 2011 and don't forget that
because there's a reason we started 2011
and then we eventually rolled it into
dotnet rock so only 130 episodes there
but we got to talk about Microsoft and
I'm gonna use their logos to set the
timescale so when you see this logo what
do you think do you think disco cuz
you'd be about right right that's 1975
right Microsoft was formed because of
this computer the M set 8800 this is the
device that convinced Bill Gates to drop
out of Harvard and move to Albuquerque
New Mexico with his friend Paul Allen to
write a version of Basic
for this machine and if you want to see
a copy of it that's in the Computer
History Museum in outside of San Jose
California it's an ache a basic and this
was one of their original products and I
think it's important to remember that
Microsoft started as a programming
languages company and they had a mantra
that was very much around how software
unlocked the exponential experience of
computers see up until this point when
you bought a computer it came with
software the software was specific to
the machine which means each machine you
bought had different software on it and
it wasn't all that good because it was
free it was included in the box and Bill
knew that he wanted to uncouple that
that he wanted common software Dirk
report across multiple machines it takes
time to build hardware the hardware is
always falling behind so making the
software increment independently and
research independently who's going to
make all the difference and in that
timeframe is when he also wrote the open
letter to hobbyists because of course
hobbyists were sharing software the idea
that software cost money was an anomaly
bill also invented the end-user License
Agreement that thing you click OK to
that's Bill because it does two things
one is it talks about the fact that you
have not actually bought this software
but you've bought the right to use it
and at the limit of the warranty of the
software is how much you spent on it not
how much it ruined your life right so
I'm afraid a thousand years from now we
may remember Bill only for his EULA
although I think curing malaria might
beat that out but let's fast-forward up
to the 1980s Microsoft again you can
tell by the logo and that's when
Microsoft completely changes because of
DOS now they're writing an operating
system but the mantra is still true
they're writing software that runs
across machines one of the reasons they
got involved with das is that the way
that IBM was making that machine there
could be clones there are multiple
companies making these machines and they
could write an operating system we went
across all of them so the exponential
effect of software continued to apply
but the operating system would start to
consume them it would change the way the
company operated they started selling it
on the base
if you sell a computer you pay us for a
license of das and that naturally morphs
into Windows and that takes us to the
1990s version of Microsoft so the 1990
version of Microsoft they have now made
Windows has become a thing they've
created the 32-bit jump with Windows 95
and bridged that gap and they're
continuing to build multiple development
tools and this is our set up to talk
about dotnet the first version of Visual
Studio in 97 had this array of products
in it so their core product really was
C++ they've been making a version C++
for a long time
Visual Basic was relatively newer coming
along in 91 though now it's 97 and since
the second to last version of VB they
had bought visual foxpro and kept it in
the box
visual j plus plus is microsoft's
implementation of java written by andrew
Salzburg that's what Bill had hired him
away from Borland to do this now won't
last very long for various reasons but
that's what was going on there it was a
very well received version of Java
visual inner dev is one of Microsoft's
first attempts to build tooling for the
web the internet tidal wave letter that
Bill put out in 95 roughly a year and a
half on when this is when this actually
is around this is their attempted
tooling yeah under dev doesn't last very
long and nobody is unhappy about that
and we still have visual sourcesafe
enough set a year later it's interesting
to see that there was this idea with
Visual Studio that it would be a
consolidated development environment
they had all these different teams
building products and they all had to
build their own IDE their own editing
environments their own debugging tools
it was expensive so they had this idea
that they wanted to consolidate and so
here was Visual Studio which had a
shared IDE it was shared between j plus
plus an inter dev because vb c c++ and
and FoxPro all had their own but it was
in the same box and a year later they
renumber Devery thing to six cuz naming
by years is too easy
let's call everything six and in fact
we'll rename all the products
- so it's vb6 in c++ 6 which were
actually sixes it's inner dev 6 which is
actually the second version of Internet
and the last and j+ plus 6 which is the
third edition although it was really
numbered - and it's also the last
because microsoft's implementation of
java focuses on running windows
extremely well and that upset sun
microsystems and is it technically in
violation of the agreement they had and
so a lawsuit ensues and by the end of 98
Microsoft can have nothing to do with
Java whatsoever
now that's June of 98 the core issues
around dotnet are already fomenting
nobody set out to make dotnet dotnet
emerged from a set of problems but
another problem that's happening right
then and you need to talk about it to
understand what was going on inside of
Microsoft involves these guys now I love
this picture it's a Getty picture
because they look so happy
alright this is taken in July of 1998
shortly after studi studio 6 had shipped
and right before the Department of
Justice comes after Microsoft in a big
way you gotta understand how big a deal
this was it's 20 years ago now but in
June of 95 this is the cover of Time
Bill Gates is the master of the universe
this will change three years later he's
being deposed by the US Senate and you
can watch this deposition on YouTube if
you care to it does not go well bill
does not help his cause he doesn't know
why he's there
he doesn't wanna understand why he's
talking to these idiots and he is the
polite term would be recalcitrant and it
kicks off a really fierce investigation
and lawsuit that lands in November of 99
that's the time cover you've gone from
master of the universe to four years
later busting bill where
Microsoft in November of 1999 is
declared a ma a pernicious monopoly and
ordered to break up into two companies
an operating system company and in
everything else company now this hits
bill pretty hard and this is a photo
from the pre-press conference just a few
years later like again compare that to
that Getty picture he's stepping down as
CEO and his friend Steve is taking over
it happened fast and it was a huge
impact now he doesn't leave Microsoft he
B focuses on being chief architect so
he's working mostly internally into the
organization where Steve's on the front
lines and his lots of software people
that think that this was a mistake and I
can understand why people feel that way
but as I've studied this in more detail
I feel like Steve Ballmer was the right
guy at the right time because he fought
back successfully against the government
by November 2001 he they signed a
consent decree that stops the company
from being broken up keeps it in one
police in peace but he has certain rules
they have to abide by making source code
available to certain companies so they
can see how Windows works and take
advantage of it because that was the
argument in the DOJ all along there was
an unfair advantage but at that time you
started to see the first whisperings of
what will ultimately become dotnet in
February of 2003 a month after Steve
takes over as CEO he talks about ng WS
or next-generation Windows services
although in a few months it'll be next
generation web services but it wasn't
even dotnet then it was other ideas
about what happened next for development
and so if you want to put together
dotnet you have to talk about a variety
of people with a variety of missions and
these are only representatives they
behind these three individuals are
literally thousands of folks
so first is Brian Harry
Brian Harry wrote visual sourcesafe and
Microsoft bought him and his company and
visual sourcesafe
and he worked on it for a number of
years but as sourcesafe ran its limit
round version six part a Studio 98 he
got moved to another project and the
project was about managing runtimes
so the issue is this the C++ team has a
run time right it was MFC and atl the VB
team has a run time the Fox team has a
run time and every time Windows makes a
change all of these teams go into a
tizzy to try and get those things
implemented or not as the case may be
and then customers are frustrated
because they've seen new features on
Windows and they don't have them in
their development environment of choice
doesn't it make sense that we would make
one run time a common run time that
would allow all of these languages to
take advantage of those new features on
Windows as quickly as possible that is
the project that Brian Harry is leading
now this will eventually become the
common language runtime and Brian will
be part of shipping 1.1 oh and 1.1 and
then he will go to begin work on what
will eventually come team foundation
server so he's only in for the first
couple of years the next problem space
mr. Howells burg now brought on board to
do Java can't do Java anymore and one
would argue if Sun had not done this
would we all be programming in Java
because ultimately what he did was go
back to basics having understood what
Java did and he made AC like language
that was object-oriented as in C object
oriented language cool and you'll see
that cut if you go over doing around the
old Docs you'll find that code name and
that namespace referenced every so often
it was the precursor to what would
become c-sharp anders also firmly
believed in the idea of a common set of
base class libraries again in that time
of programming the late 90s part of your
job as a developer was to pick the
toolset not just your editing
environment but what libraries were you
going to use
well what database are we going to
communicate with which library makes the
most sense for that what
working stacker we're gonna work on
because tcp/ip hasn't won yet at this
time you're arguing over each one of
those pieces and Anders firmly believe
that it should be one set a common set
that everybody will run here now besides
making working on c-sharp he also built
a product called 2j sharp and J sharp
was a bridge for his j+ + developers to
be able to move to c-sharp
anders cares very deeply about
developers you talk about the heart and
soul of microsoft support for developers
a lot of that power comes from Anders
House Berg to this day third another
fellow we're going to see on Friday mr.
Guthrie in 1997 fresh out of Duke
University joins Microsoft it is his
first and only job he's never worked
anywhere else he joins the NT option
pack team part of studio six working
under guy named David Treadwell and his
direct reporters a guy named Mark Anders
and they implement the next version of
active server pages as part of I is for
in the NT option pack ships in November
of 98
that's studio six now normally when a
product ships everybody takes a couple
of weeks off you've gone through a def
March not easy to push product out so
they take a break but it's the end of
November and so those first two weeks
are gonna be December and then it's
Christmas time so for the most part the
team takes off for all over December but
mr. Guthrie in 1997 is in his early 20s
and he has just gotten the job of his
dreams and he doesn't really feel like
not working and he doesn't really want
to go back to North Carolina Christmas
either so he stays in apartment and an
apartment and works through that entire
month prototyping something better ASP
plus was the code name that he was
prototyping and he what he wanted was
something that worked through iis and
worked in that namespace but also was
object oriented to its roots and that
could be more better programming model
than what ASP represented and he got a
prototype working in that month that was
shown off in January and the language
that they were programming
was Java that's what they had for
object-oriented languages at the time so
in January of 98 when they show it when
he shows it off they go that's really
cool keep going on this you got to get
rid of Java and that becomes a scramble
that's a whole bunch of other stories so
I bring this viewpoint out to recognize
none of these folks were focused on
something called dotnet they were
focused on solving three distinctly
different problems a common runtime a
new language a way to get to the web
that was more sophisticated than what
had been done so far by 2000 they start
to have prototypes together they sort of
bump into each other I originally anders
wasn't building a language with a common
runtime he ran into the common runtime
team and that had that created a
separate conversation one of the huge
debates around that was managed memory
should we do garbage collection or
should we do reference counting huge
debate internally that would then
propagate out into the world as well but
all of those fights happened inside of
Microsoft now at the time Microsoft has
been iterating very quickly when you get
to 2000 you think about 97 with studio
97 98 with studio 6 on the window side
95 98 98 SC Windows 2000 right there so
every everything on Microsoft is firing
a rapid order delivering new versions
but by July of 2000 has been two years
since there's been anything out of any
of the dev teams Studio six shipped in
98 now it's 2000 they have this PDC and
they kind of blindside everybody with an
announcement of this thing they do call
at that time dotnet but there's also
some political playing going on here
remember that Microsoft's been declared
in monopoly in November of 99 in order
to break up in January of 2000 and Steve
is no negotiating the consent decree at
that time and so one of the things they
say in these announcements is that this
will be a new platform based on internet
standards and they publish c-sharp as an
ECMO circuit and the
CLR as a necklace specification so
they're showing that Microsoft is open
not necessarily open-source but open its
positioning to negotiate with the
government which will succeed but we
didn't know this at the time all we saw
was a whole new environment nobody
thought there was gonna be a big show we
were all kind of surprised by it I'm
like wow why didn't you tell anybody
it's like we wanted surprising Windows
2000 ships this time now this is a big
deal version of Windows because this
consolidates the NT line and the 9x line
it wasn't a great version of Windows it
was a good version of Windows but it did
a lot of important underpinning work
this is also when Microsoft goes tcp/ip
first the other networking stack still
exists but you default on tcp/ip this is
also where they abandon alpha MIPS and
PowerPC the earlier versions of NT
actually ran on different platforms this
is the version where they go it's Intel
so if you actually want to talk about
the wind tell hegemon it starts here
with 2000 and it's also when we first
started to get gigahertz processors in
the form of the early Pentiums by 2001
they shipped now actually before October
of 2001 two things happen in July of
2001 a very young Miguel de Icaza all of
29 years old has run with the Ekman
specifications that Microsoft had
published and then an O'Reilly
conference says he's going to create
mono that's the beginning of a Linux
implementation of dotnet based on the
open standards in August of 2001 ie6
ships based on internet standards that
are not ratified and in at same time
when as dotnet drops the first version
XP comes out now we called at the time
XP we have a fond memory of XP that is
not from 2001 it's actually from about
2005 but in 2001 this thing didn't even
support USB it was almost not there yet
we call this Windows 2000 with the
fisher-price interface because it had a
nice curve
three colorful buttons and so forth and
but it's also what our things are gonna
look like right that this was the new
generation of software was gonna look
like moving forward and this operating
system utterly dominates the landscape
this is 96% of desktops within a few
years are running XP the whole world
runs one operating system now before
this is released earlier in 2001 we have
this tremendous outbreak of malware the
Anna Kournikova virus is a February of
2001 code red worm in July of 2001 Code
Red - in August the nimda worm in
September it's just a debacle of
constant hacking every month another
announcement and by January of 2002
gates these days a chief architect not a
CEO puts out his internet security
letter he calls it trustworthy computing
and the main thing he says is to the
entire organization stop what you're
doing focus on security now for the XP
team what did this mean XP is are is
already well underway and service pack 1
is already defined it's all the stuff
they're already cutting to get shipped
right so XP service pack 2 is going to
be the security fix and one would argue
that Microsoft made a mistake at this
moment because XP sp2 will be a breaking
change to Windows the enforcement of
significant security rules is where UAC
comes from all of those sorts of things
will break software they probably could
have called it XP version 2 but they
didn't they call it a service pack as
they wanted everybody to install it that
begins now January of 2002 and by
February of 2002 we get our first
version of.net it ships and this is the
first version of c-sharp really the
first time we've seen it it's a it's
Microsoft's from scratch written
object-oriented language all the way
down of course it runs against the CLR
foxpro goes its own way in the same time
span the rotor project starts this is a
shared source implementation of dotnet
you know one of the jokes that was said
back in 2014 when they open source
dotnet was maybe the third time's a
charm so one of those early attempts was
at this time frame with rotor I have
some of the original marking material
that's been sent to me from 2002 and the
pitch line for this version of.net was
22 languages one platform now can you
name 22 languages much less 22 languages
it's supposedly ran in dotnet took me a
while I found the whole list see if your
language lists on this list but yeah
there's some crazy there was a version
of Python there any dotnet okay some of
these I'm not entirely sure languages
and some of these are still supported to
this day their third-party and you have
to pay for them but IBM steel ships a
version of Fortran net and Fujitsu still
ships a version of COBOL dotnet and
originally c-sharp was called c-sharp
net until everybody figured out that's
dumb now it's just called c-sharp the
the 1.1 edition comes out less than a
year later in April of 2003 and it is
the bug fix Edition they fix a lot of
things but as people are now starting to
excellent exercise this development
environment they're finding non-trivial
problems and so the big push goes 2.0
they're gonna there that's where they're
really trying to do some fixes and it'll
take a couple of years to get there so
they put out one in 2002 they put at 1.1
in 2003 they won't ship the third
version called version 2 until 2005 and
in the meantime there's trouble brewing
in the windows world
so at PDC 2003 in Los Angeles was the
first time we heard about Windows
Longhorn
now the codename for XP was Whistler and
Whistler is ski mountain not far from
where I live the next version of Windows
codename was actually black
and Blackcomb never saw the light of day
it was a dotnet version of Windows top
to bottom they spend two years on it and
then they abandon it in 2003 and if you
ever go to the Whistler village where
the Whistler mountain and the Blackcomb
mountain are side-by-side they even got
a gong to logos between them at the
bottom between these two mountains is a
very large bar called the long horn bar
and so the backed off version of
Blackcomb was called Longhorn now one of
the reasons that Microsoft even talked
about this is that coming out of the
consent decree was this understanding
that people don't understand that
Microsoft is a bunch of developers a
bunch of people engineers building
things and so this was the beginning of
a more open Microsoft where guys like
Robert Scoble started running around
with a camera and showing you the people
that were building the products and so
the choice at PDC to announce we're
building a new version of Windows this
what it looked like was all part of that
response to the consent decree and this
you know Microsoft being the board
mentality trying make them appear more
human again
one would argue this is a blunder
because they were showing things that
were far from ready but they showed off
at this time the three pillars of Avalon
indigo and Wynn FS Avalon was the new
drawing system that was going to be
amazing and beautiful and superfast when
FS were wet indigo was the
communications library that was going to
interoperate within the machine across
machines across the internet working
exactly the same way and when FS was an
object-oriented file system you know in
August of 2004 they finally ship XP
service pack 2 and you got to think
about what was happening to the windows
team in this time frame in order to do
that set of security fixes they had
taken many of the most senior Microsoft
people guys who knew the deepest
underpinning of Windows and we were all
pouring their energy into the service
pack while the new version of Windows
which started as black oh and then
became long horn is being worked on by
everyone else so it's not until service
pack 2 ships that the team kind of comes
together and focuses on what's the
situation of long horn and they know
there's a deadline a deadline that most
people have forgotten about because
Microsoft had been is such just
incredible cadence of shipping operating
systems every year or every other year
and now it's 2004 and they have not
shipped one someone's reminded them of
what the real deadline is so most large
organizations buy their software from
Microsoft via a volume license agreement
the volume License Agreement doesn't
really say it's this many copies of that
and this many copies of this and so
forth what it really says is how many
employees have you got we'll give you a
flat rate per employee and you get
everything and then they just try
encourage you to actually use it but
buried in those volume license
agreements are guaranteed delivery dates
for certain products and one of those
products is an operating system which
they guarantee a new version of every
five years and xp it shipped in November
of 2001 and is now August of 2004 and so
they've got till November of 2006 and
they're nowhere they had called sp2
version two they could have reset the
counter but they didn't for the reasons
I previously stated and so now the
windows team is under a serious time
crunch trying to get a version of
Windows though now over on the dotnet
side life's pretty good because in 2005
they ship the third version of.net
although the CLR is numbered version two
because you know version numbers are fun
one of the reasons the CLR 2 arguably is
the best version of CLR they ever made
is that they made a version for sequel
server sequel Server 2005 had dotnet
running inside of it I'm not saying it's
a good idea right now the motivation is
pretty straightforward there were
certain large customers of Microsoft's
financial services companies typically
out of the Northeast United States that
had a need for sophisticated languages
working against data in near real time
and so querying against a database that
was receiving all this data took too
long they wanted to do the analysis
inside of the database now today we do
that with reactive frameworks or
streaming systems but this is 2004
people do not to do that yet thought
that way and typical of customers like
supposedly said al it's actually true if
I'd asked a customer what they wanted
they would have said faster horses what
the customer wanted was a database with
a sophisticated language and so there
was a requirement to put c-sharp inside
of sequel server the side-effect of that
by lifting the CLR out of windows and
running in the sequel context they made
it dramatically better it was smaller it
was faster it was far more reliable
it was the industrial-strength version
of.net and one would argue the original
mission of dotnet of building a high
quality development environment that
worked from nominally well in Windows
and let you work in the language of your
choice comes to fruition here we've got
in 2.0 generics and partial classes we
have anonymous types we're setting up
for a link we're not there yet and
nobody officially knows that internally
they're already debating it we're headed
in that particular direction this is
also the version that's first supported
64-bit operating systems so this is
where we got compile any which was great
as long as you only compiled 32 as soon
as you actually tried to compile 64 your
software didn't work it was pretty
simple so and they also got rid of the
dotnet it's Visual Studio right we're
all together now so the windows team is
in a terrible crisis the same time the
dotnet team produces arguably the best
version of.net so the CLR the language
all these things that come together very
well it's the web that's still
struggling folks are not they're
productive with web forms but they don't
love them they're trying to find a
better way to do things and Microsoft
puts together new conference called mix
and it was to focus on web development
and a few things came out of this very
first mix one was Internet Explorer 7 it
had been six years or five years right
this comes out in October of 2006 ie 60
come out in August of 2001 where did
they been all that time the IE team was
the team responsible for example they
were building Avalon that's where they
went
and now they were done and so they came
back in mid a new version of ie
and we heard the first rumblings of
something called WPF II but I'll talk
about that in just a minute so November
of 2006 Vista ships only the Enterprise
Edition the one required by the volume
license agreement
nobody installs it well that's not true
none of us installed it because we're
don't have Enterprise licenses so we
don't need to install it no Enterprise
guys installed because Enterprise guys
know better
you wait for Service Pack 1 the only
people that install it are the magazine
review guys right Daryl taps and the
pulse rots and they find out it's not a
good version of Windows it shipped with
some serious problems now there's a
whole bunch of reasons why this is true
one of them being that volume License
Agreement deadlines Hardware had changed
a bunch of the component models have
changed and so Vista struggled mightily
it will be fixed by May of 2007 with
Service Pack 1 which will also be the
release of all of the other editions of
Vista it'll be fixed and it'll be fine
and it'll be too late my mother will
tell me I don't want that version of wit
of Windows I'm like I don't think you're
qualified for an opinion but ok and it's
important to remember that in that same
time frame well the other thing that
happens as this happens is they put out
an emergency version of.net dotnet 3 and
this is where Windows presentation
foundation windows communication
foundation workflow and card space all
come from it basically all the stuff
they hold out a long horn to get out the
door with vista lands in the.net teams
lap and so they make a version of.net
3.0 which still CLR 2 in 2006 in 2007
the first iPhone appears June of 2007
Microsoft is busy they're not painted a
whole lot of mine but it wasn't a great
phone this is the beginning this was a
2g only phone and and jobs told us if
you wanted to program against that
you'll program in Safari he was
anticipating html5 he was ahead of his
time and I look
it is kind of the end of the phone
because before this phone phones were
kind of cool alright they had keyboards
and antennas and GPS modules and after
the iPhone every phone looks the same so
you know we've had 10 years of the same
flippin phone now it's just a slab of
black glass but that's fine because
we're getting new programming models and
one of them is WPF II now that was his
code name was Windows presentation
foundation extensions and our friend
Brad a burst olace if we give it a
really bad code name we get a really
great product name a product name was
Silverlight give it a good code name
like Avalon you end up with a lousy
product name like Windows presentation
foundation so you get the order right of
course the early versions here this is
programmed in JavaScript right it was
really a media playback thing if we take
a few versions before they get all it in
but their big thing that was Silverlight
is if Microsoft started I'm gonna say
Microsoft I mean Scott Guthrie starts
shipping out of and he starts doing his
own releases he's not waiting for new
versions to studio it gets confusing for
us it's hard to know what versions that
people have the things too hard to
install stuff in October of 2007
well August September October of 2007
Scott Guthrie goes on a bit of a hiring
spree he hires a bunch of folks that are
here actually guys like Rob Connery and
Phil hack I'm sitting in the back of the
room and Scott Hanselman at the time we
called them
Scott Guthrie's ninja army but they were
all pro open-source they were all big on
building great software and shipping it
when it was ready and Scott had been
working on some tooling for web
development that wasn't asp.net webforms
and there's an apocryphal story about
him going to a conference in Austin was
the first alt dotnet conference which is
a whole other conversation we probably
shouldn't have right now and he shows
off for the first time MVC to the public
he did it existed in
and I'm pretty sure it recruited some of
you guys that it was a tool that he
showed off to to his ninja army folks to
say this is why you want to come on
board but it was a revelation a testable
scalable approach to web development
coming out of Microsoft because asp.net
had always been web forms had always
been about easy to build hard to skip
and here was an alternative and it was
so breakthrough it was a real
interesting push sort of lit people up
by November of 2007 we have dotnet 3.5
so this is the cleaned-up version post
VISTA they start to build the designer
tools expression and link first appears
the beginning of that whole thing and we
get sequel link to sequel and a bunch of
other link options you know otherwise
pretty ordinary version of studio Brian
Harry reappears at this point having
worked on the CLR up to 1.1 he splits in
2003 to work on a secret project four
years later they deliver that as team
foundation server and this team system
civilize heyday really comes through and
actually web development as a whole 2008
2009 2010 a lot happens things are
moving really quickly it's in 2008 the
first version of Chrome appears ie8 is
out age the html5 specification finally
hits public draft so we're getting
serious about what html5 is going to
look like mono 2.0 comes out all in the
same timeframe keeping up with dotnet to
some degree but the version is so behind
and even a version of silverlight called
moonlight appears by the end of 2008
early 2009 and at the Microsoft PDC
conference in 2008 where they announced
Silverlight 2 we finally really see ray
Ozzy taking over for Bill as the chief
architect and his leadoff pitch is what
we'd eventually know it'd be known as a
sure the beginning of this cloud concept
it doesn't resonate particularly well at
this time but he puts out a vet letter
very much the same way that bill always
has but about Internet services and that
whole model by 2009 the windows debacle
has been cleaned up into version of when
we call Windows 7 which for many people
still their favorite version of Windows
you know nine years later we still love
win7 the guy leading that project Steven
Sinofsky came from the office team's
contemporaries and Brian Valentine and
Jim Allchin both of whom - their careers
on the rocks of delivering Vista and by
February of 2010 we have Windows Azure
the first sort of publicly facing
version it has a version of sequel
server called sequel Azure and it has
support for three development
environments dotnet Java and PHP the
timing on this is stunning so you kind
of okay we're good something's happening
in cloud this were early versions it was
not that easy to work with but we were
getting there in March of 2010 the iPad
gets announced the big iPhone is out by
April of 2010 Jobs puts out a letter
called thoughts on flash now what he
knew was that flash destroyed the
battery of the iPod and so his solution
was to not allow flash to run in Safari
and he did that by banning all add ins
and there's a strong argument for that
by getting rid of add-ins you get rid of
a whole vector of malware a bunch of
problems that average people have you
can circumvent it if you installed the
chrome version of iOS you could still
run flash if you really wanted to but he
put the heat on flash they ultimately
would stop making a mobile version of
flash because it kind of is an evil
piece of software but it impacts
Silverlight so for lights mantra had
been that we've got to be able to run
all these different places they had a
Mac version they were looking into the
platforms but it required a runtime and
if you can't get the runtime deployed
well you're gonna have trouble in April
of 2010 they ship Studio 2010 now studio
2010 was a big version it was the
version where they started implementing
WPF and a Microsoft product for the
first time WPF landed in 2006 it's been
four years but studio actually
implemented WPF
made it dramatically better this is the
first version with f-sharp this is also
the version that shipped with jQuery so
Microsoft was starting to think
differently about open sources they
would include an open source library
inside of that jQuery would end up
needing legal protection then we create
the jQuery foundation which today is now
known as the JavaScript foundation so
those are all part of these things that
happen simultaneously with 2010 and at
the same time as part this is April 2010
version 4 of Silverlight drops it
supports Chrome it runs out of the
browser the tooling in studio 2010 is
pretty solid and most of us at this time
in spring of 2010 are in a pretty happy
place because we have this ability to
program against these things and we're
open to to you know the world is our
c-sharp sam'l will do all the things and
then in the fall of 2010 PDC the last
PDC done at the Microsoft campus in
Redmond only a thousand people invited
the whole thing was streamed so you
could see it and virtually no mention at
Microsoft's premier development
conference about Silverlight and so Mary
Jo Foley who's a well-known reporter in
the Microsoft pit place written a few
books in the space asks Bob Moglia who
was president of server and tools at the
time what's up with Silverlight and bob
says our strategy has shifted but he
realized this all happened back in the
spring in march/april timeframe with
jobs as announcements Microsoft's had
been dealing with this for a while they
just hadn't told anybody because they
had to decided what they were gonna do
about it yet and this is the moment that
it gets outed in October of 2010 now a
bunch of battles will happen over at
Moglia saying this and he'll leave
Microsoft by January of 2011 and the guy
who'll take over his server and tools
role is a young man by the name of Satya
Nadella this is also the time when
anders house berg leaves the c-sharp
team mads turgidson takes over for him
and he and anderson now starts working
on a tool that will eventually be known
as type
script this in 2011 we have the Battle
of the browsers I think it was a really
amazing time to be a web developer as
html5 is maturing and being agreed upon
the big browser houses right the IE team
with the chakra engine the Google team
the chrome team with the v8 engine the
Firefox rise of Mozilla folks with
JavaScript core / nitro start going back
and forth iterating very rapidly almost
weekly releases and if you were dumb
enough to program against the new
features a week later you find out your
app doesn't work anymore but this is
where we got GPUs incorporated into
browsing and pre compilation of
JavaScript like the performance of
JavaScript goes through the roof in a
span of months starting in early 2011
and that really leads to an explosion of
a language called no Jazz no would have
been around for a couple of years before
this with this idea that JavaScript
would live outside of the browser but
it's a 2011 that it becomes abundantly
clear that JavaScript has ascended as
its own language that it's capable
outside of that context and there's many
things we can do with it and node was
one of the examples of that and
Microsoft puts on a new event called
build in September of 2011 Karl and I
were there and they were talking about
the next version of Windows Windows 8
and this focus on tablets and they
didn't talk much about dotnet the whole
time Microsoft premiere event we just
gone through this year before where they
done their premiere development not
talked about Silverlight we saw what
happened there so here we were not
having conversations about not that fact
they were talking about JavaScript they
were talking about wind Jas extensions
for JavaScript to work with windows
directly Carl and I walked out of build
at the end of it saying wow we make a
podcast called dotnet rocks
what if dotnet doesn't rock anymore and
so we started another show called the
tablet show in 2011 he saw me pull up
the slide on that that's why we were
hedging our bets we still made two dot
rocks a week
there was lots to talk about but we were
making another show just in case we know
how this turns out but at the time we
were all pretty freaked out now there's
a reason to think hard at this
particular time windows is declining and
relevance they've been losing market
share steadily ios/android you know the
length the programming lines you're
working it don't care about the platform
anymore and I went and pulled the annual
report from Microsoft for 2011 they had
a bunch of billion-dollar businesses and
with the exception of these three Xbox
Bing and Skype all of them depend on
Windows does it surprise you that
they're pretty careful with taking care
of their windows business
it's the vast majority of their income
in 2011 and we know that c-sharp isn't
going to run on all those other
platforms all right that microsoft told
us so but there was a dissenting voice
and he didn't work for Microsoft it was
this guy at the same time that Microsoft
seems to be moving towards JavaScript as
the universal programming language
across the platforms Miguel de Icaza has
implemented a thing called mono touch
which is own version of c-sharp and it
compiles into iOS code and runs on the
iPhone and in 2011 he'll put out a
version for Android as well and then his
company will be sold out from underneath
him
Novell had been supporting mono for many
many years in Novell had now run out of
money and they sold the company to
attach me an attached mate did not care
about mono and basically told Miguel lay
everybody off wind this thing down
forget about it and Miguel chose not to
he pull he called his his friend NAT
Friedman they formed a new company
called Sam Urick and they convinced
Attachmate to sell them all the assets
related to mono mono touch and mono for
Android and that is the beginnings of
xamarin and at the very moment the
Microsoft is thinking about c-sharp is
not a way to work on these new
environments this little company is
actually doing it the same
year the timing is impeccable and by
2012 we have a new version of studio now
most people remember torn at the very
studio 2012 as the all-caps version of
studio but that's what we actually cared
about right there were a few other
things that happened in 2012 this is
also when we get WinRT and NBC 4 is
released it's also when Microsoft sets
up a group called Microsoft open tech as
an independent organization that is
specifically making sure that
open-source libraries work well with
dotnet tooling again the careful
positioning what's going on and now
comes the big shift 2012 build ii built
this is when they ship windows 8 they
ship when j s 1.0 and they talk about
the app store that now has all these
great windows apps Windows 8 apps and
85% of them are built in c-sharp and
zamel the rest are C++ there's virtually
nothing built in when jazz and Microsoft
is really smart they know how to lead a
parade they figure out which way the
crowd is going and they walk in front of
them and so the market shifts we made
our statement as developers we continue
to build the product so they shortly
after that by October 2013 they put out
the next version of studio they fix the
all-caps that's the most important
correction nbc5 comes along and we start
seeing a rebirth of dotnet as a whole
and a fund that there was a schism
inside of Microsoft at this moment where
they decided which way are we going to
go and the way wasn't windows first
anymore first clear evidence of that
they renamed azure used to be windows
azure and that was microsoft azure and
they finally got themselves a new CEO in
February 2014 Satya Nadella stepped up
one of Sacha's requirements for being
seeing CEO is that bill would come back
to Microsoft one third time and by all
accounts he's now half-time at Microsoft
he's not the face of Microsoft but he's
back to that chief architect role he
reviews all the products
and he's arguably in his best role for
the company as a whole and you saw this
tone shift in 2014 by build in 2014 they
released they produce the dotnet
foundation xamarin is in that they start
creating an environment safe for open
source products to live in the dotnet
space Roselyn the compiler is a service
version of c-sharp the rewrite of
c-sharp in c-sharp which had been taking
years finishes and not only is released
it is released open source and
cross-platform wanna run in Linux knock
yourself out when running the Mac rock
yourself out they rewrote it typescript
is out and they make Windows free that's
where they announced this is at Build
2014 for any device with a screen
smaller than 9 inches which is an
extraordinary shift if you think about
from 2002 when it was 22 languages one
platform that it was all about selling
Windows now they're acknowledging that
in some cases it makes sense for Windows
to be free and by the way in this same
time frame in 2014 this is when the
html5 specification finally gets
ratified so all these things have been
moving at the same time we're finally
getting to standards and by 2015 we get
arguably the good new version of studio
the one that I still like the best the
2015 edition this is also when we get
win 10 and the battles that win 10 still
represents because it's still going on
as to what Windows is gonna look like
going forward they're changing the model
of how they deliver Windows because
they're no longer looking it as their
principal cash cow the principal cash
cow is going to be a sure the MS open
tech group that they created only a
couple years before now just rolls into
Microsoft right you should an
acknowledgment now that this is an open
source company we build open source
tools and that's part of our whole job
so this pieces all come together this is
also when Visual Studio code gets
released not certainly not going to make
any money for Microsoft since it's free
but it's also a statement about
Microsoft building really great products
for folks that may never otherwise live
in the Microsoft ecosystem in any way
and the rewrite of dotnet now take those
into play so by June of 2016 we get 1.0
which is pretty rough 1.1 in March of
2017 alongside of Studio 2017 and just
this last fall in August of 2017 with
dotnet core 2 this is where they develop
they've been developing the dotnet
standard and they sort of hit their mark
on version 2 I'm not saying it's perfect
by any stretch of the imagination but a
strong version that shows they've never
tried to migrate the existing code base
into open source the licensing was too
complicated the rules are too
complicated it was easier to rewrite it
and so as all of these things become
open-source you saw things like xamarin
abandoned their version of c-sharp they
use Rosslyn abandon their version of the
garbage collector they use Mike the
Microsoft open-source version because
it's better it turns out when you
actually look at this code under the
hood it's better than you think it's
faster than you think it's more
sophisticated anything these were really
extraordinary developers we just never
saw it before we just can see it now and
so we are here now at the beginning of
2018 I know from as a guy who talks to
developers several times a week and
receives feedback steadily that the
customer base itself is remarkably split
that there's lots of folks that are
excited about the so food source world
that core is very interesting to them
that their ability to run across
platforms is huge and there's an also a
substantial chunk of the market that
says I don't know why they built those
things that I was happy in my windows
and framework world and I'm worried
they're not working on that anymore now
you know it for me as a storyteller I'm
going on collecting the store I'm going
to the guys I'm going to the Jeff
Fritz's and they can actually tell us
what they're working on because they're
allowed to talk about that and so the
team is these things are all working in
parallel the resolution of this is not
obvious there's not one simple outcome
to all those pieces they're just moving
so the history is still being written
and we come through some really big
shifts
and our mindset and I don't know that
all of us have gone on that ride I mean
it's it's fun for me to be able to go
back and look back and to talk to the
folks that built it and sort of assemble
the story realize how fast it actually
happened I hope you felt a little
breathless they're so changed it changed
it change well we're not done yet more
is gonna come and I'll keep writing it
down thanks for your time so if I make
it a book would you buy it I yeah I just
don't think I can get those guys on
camera I wouldn't mind making it a movie
but I don't know that they'd go for it
but my current best idea in terms of and
I'll happily take questions we have a
few minutes just put up your hand we'll
run the microphone over to you I think
the way I want to write the book is I
want to tell a story of people so that
the book will be chronological but each
chapter ibly about a person and you'll
learn about that person and what they do
to.net at that time what's important and
so my goal would be for you to
understand that person well enough to
know why they made the decision they
make that's the best idea I have right
now it's a lot of writing ahead for me
it's trying to get this down to an hour
is there's a lot I didn't talk about
phone I could but it didn't and I didn't
talk about bears any other questions no
sir do you think the mark self would
have gone down the open-source route had
they not had Azure not being such such a
success did well and one would argue
that Azure has not been that successful
you know that that I think they went
down what's interesting to me as I've
assembled that narrative is recognizing
that clearly mr. Guthrie had decided on
open source somewhere in the early 2007
timeframe but he he wasn't going to lead
that fight he put these guys in front
like he started hiring up a team and
organizing things and pressing on
licenses that began in 2007 and you know
this is a big ship that they were trying
to turn
so I think the acknowledgement that this
stuff needed to head that way was aware
early on but there were plenty of forces
that were adamantly against that you
know a story that I didn't tell but I I
was there for was when they went to to
dev intersection to do the announcement
they were going to open source dotnet
Scott Guthrie or Scott hunter and Scott
Hanselman were afraid that they were
gonna get called by Redmon saying stop
it don't announce it we're still making
decisions so they turned off their
phones so that nobody could call them to
stop them until after the announcements
were made and the silly part is that
Guthrie who didn't think he was gonna be
there for it managed to get there and
then was trying to reach them to tell
him hey I can be a part of it and he
couldn't reach them cuz they turned off
their phones but yeah there were strong
forces are oppressing against that if we
go back to those billion-dollar
businesses as reason even close to
replacing again they are absolutely
betting the company on this but what's
the alternative what if they had and
what if Bill 2012 had been a huge
success when she had taken off and it
they just simply continued on that path
and never gone the direction where look
where would we be right now it's a very
interesting mental exercise because I
think we're still struggling with where
they've gone the disappointing folks
that aren't real excited about the whole
open source movement they don't care
about the cross-platform piece like
that's not important to them so we'll
and without a doubt they're splitting
their energy you've got the core team
we've got the framework team like they
can only there's only so many bodies
that can work so fast right they if they
were doing fewer more those people doing
fewer things they would go faster so
there's a price they're paying maybe
they would be in a very different spot
than they are right now
but yeah they're making they're not
doing a sure bets we can't argue with
the direction it makes a lot of sense
what they're doing and I what I
appreciate about Microsoft's approach to
this particular problem this public
computing problem is they're allowing us
still do a private with that as your
stack more and more you're seeing the
tooling will run out you know the upside
to the docker kubernetes approach run
the way you want you're not bound to
Azure
you can run on Prem you can run in
on Google cloud platform he can run on
on Amazon so you can choose a stock
that's agnostic to them if you if you
want to and they're supporting it so
they have the bets not done but all we
know for sure is they're telegraphing
with their bet is I do think what they
do better than just about anybody else
is the platform play right Amazon it
deep down is a warehouser right they are
about lowest price they're gonna be is
play all day long the cheapest VMs in
town that's what they sell it's what
they know how to sell it's what they do
Google is a very hip programming space
so hip language is hip approaches you
know they've certainly drove the
kubernetes thing forward in the first
place but a Microsoft seems to be
hitting a niche where that value add of
oh so you want to do vision resolution
here's a JSON call for you and you can
do it that I don't know that anybody
else could do as well as they are doing
so I think they found a part of how well
they execute and how coherent it is cuz
there's a part of Microsoft to me that
feels like they're very nervous they're
very anxious and everybody thinks
they're doing the right thing at the
same time and there's only so much
coordination between those groups
I mean it's Hank I think it's handsome
and had that line we are not as
organized as we would need to be to be
as evil as you think we are right
they're a very large organization of
people all thinking they're doing the
right thing but it's not the same thing
and then I say go in the same reaction
it's a part of the challenge for us on
the outside it's like so which one of
these should I use I know you we're
happily doing shows on kubernetes docker
boy makes the service traffic people
unhappy right different forces decide of
Microsoft they're all trying to solve a
problem so they're still feeling around
for - I'm optimistic sir
so I'm old enough to remember some of
these things so you went with us ride
with me I'm glass so yeah yeah it
reminds me when we fall out from our
chairs in 2000 in the PDC mm-hmm we went
for something and we got an GWS and it
was a really surprise but I'm also old
enough to start to see things coming
back at the same stuff so we used to be
C++ MFC yeah or maybe Borland and all
that stuff when dotnet cam and at that
time I remember going on with a mic and
asking the PM's saying but dotnet is
nice but there is no tooling there is no
libraries it's very very tiny and we get
what we ask in dotnet with.net core it's
the next generation okay and from people
who are doing dotnet period they don't
really care but for people like us we
are going to line up something like this
it means a lot sure and we get to the
same pass no tooling no ecosystem we are
losing windows where we were used to
have like performance counters and now
we are blind we need to do some
performance stuff and we are using third
parties friends yeah on the booth over
there okay and now the my fear is that
Microsoft is focusing on Asia I used to
work for Microsoft for six years okay
and we've seen the shift to Asia yeah
and as developers I think most of us are
developer here do you have any IND if
Microsoft is pushing some resources for
the developers and for dotnet with the
dead core well I think you answered the
question yourself the the history shows
they lay the foundation and they build
the walls in the roof so they've laid
the foundation with dotnet core I would
argue it wasn't until 2:00 that it was
feature complete enough that you can
even really say
this is a foundation we can build on so
it's only been since August I do expect
them to build more as for the shifter
without a doubt they're shifting to
Azure but consistently when they get
pressure from their customers say I love
that feature can I have it on Prem - we
get it they're not going to build it on
a whim but you know dotnet messaging the
whole message framework that Clements
vaster strove started out as a dotnet
product got yanked into Azure only and
then when we screamed loud enough a
window across platen dependent version
came back out again so I think you're
gonna continue to see that oscillation
right that yeah Azure is always going to
come first but it doesn't preclude
there'll be non Azure versions of
anything we demand they are listening
and you can participate in their
conversations now right the the the
funny thing is they still appear
secretive even though they're doing
everything in the open because we can't
keep up with how fast they put stuff out
like everybody's wondering what's gonna
happen with sam'l standard if you want
to know go read the github repository
the fights are going on in public
you just can't read them cuz they're
long and there's lots of them so you go
in and look at a bunch of the Azure
tooling stuff that's in github you'll
see that there's plans for for off as
your versions of them but it's Asia and
you you just keep all the the phone and
and we know T and uwp stuff that's us as
developer they just remove all that
stuff now that's an issue I think it's a
separate conversation that's what you're
saying there about what about on premise
the client-side development the uwp
stuff my point is the amount of
resources that Microsoft is pushing if
you take a look at the github stuff ya
look at the dotnet core and the number
of people working on them and look at
the same for Asia it's like 100 more or
measure than yeah I wouldn't disagree
cuz I sure has to come first but
eventually what they're building in
Azure winds down and those guys still
need jobs they lose their developers I
don't yeah that's a good question and I
think it's always a race but you've
described the race they've played many
times right we were happy
B C++ MSC devs when they brought out
this new platform and said this is the
way and we're like except for the part
where it's really crappy right and then
it got better and they did pull people
off the MSC libraries and off the VB
library so those those guys didn't lose
their jobs they moved over and worked on
the new stuff and gradually the tooling
got better is it a race absolutely it's
a race but they've won it before maybe
we'll go away and come back like there's
lots of folks doing that now folks that
are really frustrated with where
Microsoft was at in 2011 2012 that went
off into other development environments
and now find themselves wandering back
because they're kind of interested in
where we are right now so it isn't gonna
be a painless path alright that much I'm
sure and I have no engine cider
knowledge than that all I have is the
historical reference so I think they'll
get there not this week thanks sir
going open-source for Microsoft what's a
quite big thing yeah if you can say like
what are the thoughts inside Microsoft
right now like are you thinking that
maybe there are some people there who
are thinking of again closing the source
or this is the way forward the biggest
thing that's happened to Microsoft now
is that the legal department understands
open source so the there are relatively
few things that senior people at
Microsoft fear but Microsoft legal they
fear so and why I can't remember his
name
they hired the chief counsel from Sun
that wrote the original open source
licenses and that's what got them across
I remember interviewing him like 6 or 7
years ago so deep down Microsoft now
understands from a legal corporate
perspective how to open source things
and why you keep them open source so
there's no way for them to go backwards
that is not more damaging to the company
than going forward so I wouldn't worry
about that aspect
now are there anti open source
contingents inside of Microsoft yes
there are but they're losing and they're
getting old and died right this is an
old Einstein rights general relativity
in the 20s and all the old physicists
hate it criticized
and so forth and the new the new
physicists embrace it and an Einstein
gets interviewed on the radio and says
if when do you see a universal adoption
of general relativity as a model for the
universe he says well first the old
physicists have to die all right so we
have had a radical shift at a contingent
of Microsoft is all on board it's the
only way they think and there's a bunch
that don't and that so we're gonna feel
that pressure for quite some time until
they move on I don't want them to die
but retirements not out of the question
they have a lot of money if they've been
with Microsoft for twenty years where
the stock price has gone in the past
five go home you're okay
but they're you know the interviews
we've been doing the conversation been
having the windows code base is in get
now you know think about that
so DevOps practices and common source
code repository practice is a
modernization of the way that Microsoft
builds software has now penetrated the
most recalcitrant portions of Microsoft
with office and single server and
windows those original Bastion
organizations that could resist
everything new even they are being moved
and that says to me they're on a one-way
path you nobody moves source code cuz
it's fun it's not the largest source
code library in the world Windows now
lives in get that's a one-way trip so
I'm pretty confident that those moves
are current that this is now the path is
everything Microsoft going to be able to
source probably not and not everything
should be right but this new philosophy
is not a temporary part of Microsoft it
is a permanent part of Microsoft that
folks have a great show we got two more
days to go pace yourself it's a marathon
there's lots to do Carl and I'll be
recording shows every day in the
afternoons with a little booth in the
back corner there by all means peek in
if the doors closed or recording but in
between love to say hi and shake your
hand thanks so much for coming out
you